>>> OPENING STATEMENTS THIS
MORNING AS THE SEDITION TRIAL OF
FIVE OATH KEEPER MEMBERS GETS
UNDER WAY.
THEY'RE ACCUSED OF TRYING TO
OPPOSE THE LAWFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER ON JANUARY 6th.
>> THESE FIVE PEOPLE ARE THE
FIRST AMERICANS TO GO ON TRIAL
FOR SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY IN
CONNECTION WITH THE JANUARY 6th
ON THE CAPITOL.
IT'S THE MOST SERIOUS CHARGE
ANYONE FACED FROM THAT DAY AND
RARE.
>> IT'S UNPRECEDENTED IN THE
SENSE WE HAVE NEVER HAD A
VIOLENT DISRUPTION OF THE
TRANSFER OF POWER FROM ONE
PRESIDENT TO THE OTHER.
THAT MAKES THIS A UNIQUE EVENT.
>> Reporter: THIS IS SOME OF THE
HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF VIDEOS THAT
PROSECUTORS CAN USE.
IT SHOWS THREE OF THE FIVE ON
TRIAL, THE ALLEGED MEMBERS OF
THE OATH KEEPERS WEARING COMBAT
GEAR, WALKING IN A MILITARY
STACK FORMATION AND BREACHING
THE CAPITOL.
THAT IS 40-YEAR-OLD JESSICA
WATKINS OF OHIO, AN ARMY VETERAN
CELEBRATING.
WITH HER, KENNETH HARRELSON OF
FLORIDA SHOWN HERE INSIDE THE
CAPITAL AND 53-YEAR-OLD FLORIDA
MAN KELLY MEGS.
THE ONLY ONE WHO IS NOT A
MILITARY VETERAN OF THE FIVE.
TWO OF THE CHARGED NEVER MADE IT
INSIDE THE CAPITOL BUT THEY TOO
PLANNED AND PLOTTED TO VIOLENTLY
STOP THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER PROSECUTORS SAY.
>> EVERY SINGLE ONE IN THERE IS
A TRAITOR.
>> Reporter: THAT IS THOMAS
CALDWELL TALKING ABOUT THE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS INSIDE.
DAYS BEFORE THE ATTACK, HE
MESSAGED THE GROUP ABOUT A PLAN
TO HAVE WEAPONS READY AND
WAITING.
WE COULD HAVE THE QUICK RESPONSE
TEAM WITH THE WEAPONS STANDING
BY.
BUT THE HIGHEST PROFILE IN THAT
GROUP IS ARMY VETERAN STEWART
RHODES FROM TEXAS.
THE FOUNDER.
THE OTHER FOUR ON TRIAL ARE HIS
TOP LIEUTENANTS.
>> THEY BELIEVE IN A TYRANNICAL
GOVERNMENT OUT TO GET PEOPLE AT
EVERY TURN.
IT IS REALLY A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF WHAT THE ANTI-GOVERNMENT
MILITIA MOVEMENT REPRESENTS IN
MODERN TIMES IN THE U.S.
>> Reporter: RHODES, A YALE LAW
SCHOOL GRADUATE AND LATER
DISPARRED ATTORNEY CAN BE SEEN
OUTSIDE THE CAPITOL.
PROSECUTORS SAY HE PLANNED FOR
CONFRONTATION.
HE SENT THIS MESSAGE TO MEMBERS
IN DECEMBER SAYING IF JOE BIDEN
TAKES THE PRESIDENCY, IT WILL BE
A BLOODY AND DESPERATE FIGHT WE
HAVE TO FIGHT.
THAT CAN'T BE AVOIDING.
IT MAKES NO DIFFERENCE WHETHER
RHODES BREACHED THE CAPITOL OR
ORCHESTRATED FROM OUTSIDE.
>> HE WAS SENDING OTHER PEOPLE
IN TO DO DIRTY BUSINESS.
OSAMA BIN LADEN DIDN'T FLY INTO
THE WORLD TRADE CENTER BUT HE'S
EQUALLY CULPABLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED ON SEPTEMBER 11th.
>> Reporter: THE DEFENSE IS
EXPECTED TO ARGUE THEY CAME TO
WASHINGTON AS PEACE KEEPERS AND
BELIEVED PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
WOULD INVOKE THE INSURRECTION
ACT.
THE ACT IS FROM THE 1800s AND
GIVES PRESIDENTS EMERGENCY
POWERS TO DEPLOY THE MILITARY TO
QUELL UNREST.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
DEFENSE?
>> IT'S GRASPING AT STRAWS.
THE INSURRECTION ACT WAS NOT
INVOKED SO EVERYTHING THEY DID
WAS DONE WITHOUT ANY COFVER OF
THE INSURRECTION ACT.
PROSECUTORS ARE GOING TO BRING
UP TONS OF EVIDENCE THEY HAVE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MESSAGES
BETWEEN THE GROUP, HOURS OF
VIDEO.
BUT FIRST THEY'RE GOING TO START
THEIR OPENING STATEMENTS THIS
MORNING HERE IN D.C.
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THE JURY
IS MADE UP OF 12 PEOPLE AND FOUR
ALTERNATES AND THIS CASE COULD
TAKE UP TO SIX WEEKS.
>> SARAH SIDENER LIVE FOR US IN
WASHINGTON THIS MORNING, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.